my name is Mike jilla I wrote the score
for seventh heaven and it's scored four
woodwinds and strings and piano and I'm
the pianist and also the percussionist
because we have a snare drum here as
well today and we're trying to cover an
awful lot of bases in terms of the
characters that's why the Frank the
woodwind player Frank macchia is playing
six different instruments at a time
walnuts I'm Frank monkeys playing six
instruments that range from the soprano
saxophone to the bass clarinet to the
whistle to the whistle which he needs to
play louder and longer ok and of course
me that nicole garcia is playing our
violins as far as the structure of the
piece goes I had done the score
originally in 2004 for the Academy for
violin cello and piano and
synchronization was extremely difficult
because of film speed and because of
slight variations between the DVD that i
have in the film so I structured this to
have sections of improvin moosic piano
improvisation and then I cue the
musicians in at appropriate times
sometimes they're free to play what they
want to play in terms of the meter well
that shouldn't say to me there but the
speed that they play it it's based more
on what's going on on-screen so I'm not
really conducting or dictating a
particular tempo to them at that time
the advantage to doing it this way is
when the film speed goes out of sync
with the score we can catch up with in
xq because we're going based on a visual
cue so regardless of how much space is
there we're able to catch up because of
the improvisational nature i play all
the lovely sweet and things of hers
which I absolutely love the score is
actually going to favorites score so far
I also play along the times with this
melody
the bass clarinet that I'm doing is kind
of comes in at times on some of the kind
of more dark kind of frightening at
times kind of elements when you say
the instrument that if you own it you
are considered a geek or a nerd is the
alto clarinet which is in between the
regular b-flat clarinet in the bass
clarinet and it's not used all that much
but it's upper register which Michaels
ring really nicely for hopefully I'll
get a sound on this ax which probably
everybody knows from most jazz things
but Michaels use the saxophone for kind
of but the male theme I think here's one
little thing he's kind of threw in there
was a couple of scenes with bugles of
going to war
you